des deux dernières années jean marie
bigard est passé du statut d'humoriste à
celui de militant politique jamais avare
d'un coup de gueule contre le
gouvernement il s'est d'abord illustré
par son soutien au gilet jaune on est
que avant de s'attaquer directement au
gouvernement lors de la pandémie sur la
question de la réouverture des bars et
ils sont aux ordres du pognon mais
jean-marie se sert aussi beaucoup des
réseaux sociaux pour faire passer ses
idées et partager ses coups de gueule
comme lorsqu'il avait interpellé le
ministre de la santé olivier véran
levier véreux de mes côtés plus
récemment il a exprimé des doutes quant
à la bonne foi du président de la
république dans le documentaire
complotistes nommé hold up
j'ai dit au président franchement vous
attrapez le coc vide
est ce que vous faites le le protocole
du professeur où tu m'as dis bien sûr le
jour même des publications qui ont été
signalées par plusieurs internautes et
qui lui ont valu la suspension de son
compte début janvier des sorties très
contestée jugé complotistes par certains
alors comprenez vous que les réseaux
sociaux sont sur jean marie bigard et
jean marie est avec no mercy jean-marie
d'être là merci merci merci je t'aime
après voilà tu sais que je t'aime je te
l'a jamais bonjour marie quoi qu'il
arrive tu le sais et c'est vrai que
voilà en ce moment il ya un truc autour
de toi c'est toutes les vidéos sont
censurés c'est à dire oh mince et plus
subtil que ça qu'on me coupe carrément
pendant 48 heures à cause des
algorithmes soi disant toi dans une
phase tu mets [ __ ] et macro et
l'algorithme unis up dans le couple 48
heures tu mets pas la série à
[Rires]
[Musique]
non mais alors pour parler sérieusement
on m'a fait un trou est plus subtil
c'est qu'en fait j'ai un million deux
cent mille abonnés oui ça fait
maintenant une puissance de feu
incroyable quand même sauf que là j'ai
pu que je n'ai même pas cent mille je
touche pour cent mille personnes
moi c'est comment ils ont fait tomber
ben comment ils ont fait gens sérieux
faudrait leur demander mais par exemple
je raconte une blague
blake qui pour moi est une bague
supérieur qui fait 3 millions je fais ça
tout le temps et tout d'un coup je n'ai
pas pu faire que deux cent mille la même
blague je la mets aux grosses têtes avec
mon ami laurent qui embrasse mon lolo et
qu'on embrasse et elle fait 4 millions
parce que c'est plus mon facebook
donc moi on a marché sur mon tube
oxygène donc je balance c'est normal
alors tu balances et on va voir ce que
tu as dit précisément sur emmanuel bach
ont notamment c'est une déclaration qui
a fait pour le documentaire très
controversé hold up réalisé par pierre
barnérias et d'après ce que tu dis le
président aurait affirmé au téléphone qu
il soignerait se soignerait à la
chloroquine s'ils étaient touchés par le
courant d'un virus exact c'est à dire
c'est ce qui s'est passé devant témoin
je suis un haut-parleur chez avec le ch
avec le président donc toi je dis je
suis un coup d'oeil à mes amis et je
leur dis voilà je vais c'est incroyable
à ce que tu dit jean-marie parce que on
est en direct un sur ses victoires
c'est fou parce que ça ne prouve rien
rien n'est sûr mais non je veux dire
simplement quelle est cette conversation
qui était privée je les balances et ce
alors on passe à dahra partie parce que
moi j'ai une question à se poser
et vous allez me dire ce que vous en
pensez vous aussi c'est parti
jean marie est ce que est ce que tu
penses que c'est
cc c'est cool de près d'eux voilà de
faire référence à des conversations
privées
ce que tu penses que le prix c'est cool
coach je te dis que tu on marche sur mon
tube oxygène pourquoi tu juste avant de
mourir je je je parle c'est en fait quoi
parce que toi tu étais très proche mois
le président n'ont jamais été très
proche et a eu un moment il m'a appelé
pour dire j'aimerais parler avec vous
j'ai su et me l'a dit lui même qui
regardait toutes mes vidéos je vous
écoute je vous écoute toujours
d'ailleurs et j'ai envie de parler avec
vous voilà c'est plutôt flatteur
oui tu étais comme un fou oui oui c'est
à dire c'est quand même le sait quand
même deux présidents de deux paires sur
donc c'est lui qui sait là c'est un mec
élégant et c'est c'est un serpent ces
cas dans le livre de la jungle et
confiance à prix ronds que
oui très savamment un peu stupéfaits
d'abord d'avoir le président au
téléphone et qui n'a plus la
convivialité et dont j'ai tout
simplement dit que maudire est un pote
comme je t'appelle ma poule
j'ai envie de lui dire je le tutoie y
est je le voyais une phrase sur deux
j'ai dit franchement présidence en un
coup d'oeil
mes potes si tu as le site al corona
vieux ce qui est su fait tu fais le
traitement du professeur out et il m'a
dit oui oui mais c'était quand cet appel
je l'étais au pardon non mais quand cet
appel sais pas c'était l'avant si les
aventures non qu'il est dans le round
c'est à la mode quand il était à la
marseille pour voir le professeur a ou
bien ne brille encore en avant l'étude
en fait oui c'est à dire avant mais bon
tu josy t-il
on s'en fout mais je sais pas s'il a
fait le traitement ou pas ce que je sais
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de députés qui
se soigne à l'hydraulique l'euro qui
s'est déjà suffisant pour être
insupportable comment est-ce qu'on peut
interdire alors médicaments qu'elle
avait un médicament qui a fait ses
preuves et comment on peut cela dit l
administrer à soi même
comment alors est-ce que c'est pas dit
qu'il l'a pris parce qu'il a dit qu'il
voulait pas que je crois qu'il n'a pas
été soignée à l'hydro de cycle rugby nom
marrant quand il a eu alors vu personne
personne n'a dit ça j'ai dit simplement
ce qui m'a dit se trouve qu'il est allé
le voir pratiquement sans prévenir
personne il est allé voir le professeur
raoul et dans le monde entier le
professeur raoul tu es une star absolue
et il ya énormément de spécialistes qui
disent oui si on avait moi il m'a parlé
d'un truc le président aussi il m'a dit
oui mais jean-marie il ya la balance
bénéfice-risque toi est-ce que si on
avait utilisé l'hydraulique l'origine
dès les premiers jours en traitement est
ce qu'on aurait fait 80 mille morts
n'ont jamais de la vie
lille en russie chloroquine on l'apprend
dix ans et deux milliards de personnes
l'ont prise je regardais mon dieu tu
sais quel point je t'aime tant a aimé il
se trouve que l'âge sur ce débat là j'ai
pas vu une étude et je me suis beaucoup
intéressé sur plein de choses et en
particulier sur ce médicament l'a
d'abord là l'europe avec la médecine
mais je suis pas médecin mais le dosage
qui étaient prescrits par out il est
bien supérieur à celui qu'on prenait
pour aller dans un pays africain par
exemple donc ça n'a rien à voir et je
sais ce que je ne comprends pas à toi
qui est si intelligent pourquoi
aujourd'hui remettre le débat
ce débat là qui pour moi qui est
essentielle non mais présence est
totalement obsolète lait périmé et je
pense que ça n'a pas été bon je pense
que cela si tu veux un avis non bien sûr
mais je pense qu'au dépôt aujourd'hui
moi j'ai rappelé le coc vite demain dans
une main j'ai reed roxy coquine et dans
l'autre main je le lis trop max et je me
soigne et cinq jours après comme tous
les membres de ma famille qui ont été
contaminés je suis soigné ses deux fils
et leurs maris quoi c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait les membres de ta famille bah ils
se sont traités
ils ont été alors il ya deux traitements
il ya celui du professeur raoul tu es il
ya deux autres médecins qui associe deux
antibiotiques tous tous les trois on les
y trop max 1 l'azithromycine oui mais le
deuxième par exemple sabine pas liens
franco et qui le conseil de l'ordre a
dit être est ce le finir
le conseil dehors de téléphones r700 me
disant qu'est ce que nous fait mal dit
je soigne les gens à soigner deux mille
personnes zéro mort un seul est allé à
l'hôpital
ban a dit je saigne les gens a dit mais
vous n'avez pas le droit lui à dire
conseil des juges et lui ils lui ont dit
vous devez donner du doliprane et dire
aux gens de rentrer chez eux ou est ce
qu'on vit je rappelle un magnet j'en
arrive je comprends votre colère votre
exaspération les injonctions
contradictoires même vos têtes de turc
butin vers ans je comprends et c'est
pour ça que je veux pas du tout ici
demander aux convives bayonne il faut je
suis pour la liberté d'expression
kooples mais malgré tout vous avez un
ennemi aujourd'hui c'est trump
tranquille a pris ce médicament il a
pris en mars à titre préventif
trump il disait comme vous on nous
manipule on nous cache mais c'est rien
il suffit de prendre ça et quand il a eu
le vide quand il a une laque au vide
il n'a pas du tout pris ça alors c'est
le hula parce que aussi
il a bien muselé marion l'ambiance
change de sexe très vite ils vont
arriver
ne pensez pas que s'il avait pris ce
traitement l'ajustement il aurait
justement il se serait vanté parce que
ça lui donnait raison par rapport à
justement à toute sa théorie n'est
jamais été question pour le professeur
raoul de le prendre
d'une manière préventive non c'est le
grand jour quand il a eu la colline on
lui a pas donné sa son médecin ne lui a
pas de lampe saint-just jean marie est
ce que vous avez un problème
est-ce que vous avez rue le président
matheron depuis n'ont jamais de la vie
vous avez eu une fausse obtenant le
numéro de téléphone
il a très vite pu marcher du tout la
même j'ai été zappé comme une mère babré
à quoi vous pensez que vous en veux
brigitte au je pense oui qu'ils doivent
jouer un petit peu parce que n'avons
nous avons eu des conversations privées
qui était tout à fait élégante
donc c'est vrai que moi après j'ai
balancé parce que il
il a tenté de m'étendre mais pour moi la
tendresse qu'il a fait battante et ne
détonnent quelqu'un c'est lui dire je
vous écoute je fais ce que ce que vous
dites d'ailleurs parce qu'à un moment
j'ai réclamé des échéances et après je
les ai eus au téléphone il m'a dit vous
avez vu j'ai fait j'ai fait ce que vous
m'avez dit c'est vrai pour des échéances
pour vous le rond et me donner des trucs
où vous le voulez aujourd'hui on marie
pasquet jeux les jeux wii jeu nerveux
pas à lui personnellement oui alors vous
allez mon nom je dis simplement que
quand
non parce que je dit deux choses qui
sont très importants j'ai noté là parce
que vous pensez il faut laisser aux gens
leur libre arbitre
je pense que c'est très important si moi
je décide de me soigner avec hydroxy
quand l'hymne hésiteront max je dois
avoir le droit de le fête attendait ces
dernières n'ont et ne pas nous obliger à
prendre un traitement
ce qu'ils font acheter si tu n'es pas
vacciner c'est plus le droit de rien
j'ai pu prendre le train tu peux plus
rien j'ai donc faut pas déconner on peut
pas d'un côté nous obliger à prendre un
remède et de l'autre côté nous
interdire de prendre un traitement c'est
impossible le tout le tout je finis en
zappant tous nos médecins de vives jean
médecin de ville leur a dit vous rentrez
chez vous on est tous d'accord
oui on mari vous êtes très intelligent
vous savez très bien qu'en affirmant
sans preuves des choses quand même
qu'ils remettent est ce que j'affirme
non mais vous vous affirmez d'abord vous
tapez sur le moi ce qui me gêne c'est
pour ça que j'ai répondu oui
les raisons dit souvent les raisons ne
font pas leur boulot il modère pas vous
vous taper très fort sur les gens en
tant que personne et vous êtes soins
donc vous savez que vous êtes à l'abri
parce qu a pas de délit d' offense du
chef de l'état donc bout vous tapez sur
lui vous tapez sur des ministres en
exercice ou qui ont été en exercice vous
les accusez je suis je suis avec
l'anneau ben oui mais moi ça me semble
normal avec la notoriété que vous avez
énoncer des vérités scientifiques en
vous prenant pour un médecin un
scientifique éminent ono géant méconnu
dont le seul but est dangereux
jean-marie ce que vous ferez de hors jeu
je suis chez d'accord avec toi mais en
revanche sur les faits sur ce qui se
passe réellement je peux quand même
ouvrir ma gueule les dans ce pays que tu
ouvres ta gueule on te coupe la tête et
c'est ça que je peux venir dire quand
même les jean-marie je peux venir dire
que moi me coupe la parole
jean-marie équipe qui vous coupe la
parole à votre avis ben euh peu
nos gouvernants ils ont plutôt intérêt à
ce que je ferme ma gueule qui coupe la
parole de des grands médecins des des
grands spécialistes par exemple de la
rn7 femme qui s'appelle ans julio en
rayon comme par exemple cette somme a
été viré de son poste dans l'ue a viré
absolument tout l été déchu de tous ses
pouvoirs de ces études de tout on a fait
ça fait ça avec le professeur peron est
ce que le professeur peron est un
charlatan un tout le monde nous envient
le talent du professeur péroné a été
jeté comme une mère de tout s'est passé
quand même bien une punition mais qu'est
ce qu'on reproche donc de trop faire de
vidéos où les gens qui est tous les gens
qui disent fait le ce ton facebook tu
dis moi je suis désolé pour le vaccin
par exemple je ne veux pas commun
modifie génétiquement qui autour de
cette table peut me dire que je rends
pas plus ce service aux gens en ne
voulant pas me faire vacciner que en me
faisant vacciner moins cher qu'un des
grands génétique puis tout ce que ça
modifie pas là des médecins pour me dire
maman de femmes
ces médecins qui se trouve que la fin
qui est de la grande spécialiste de la
rm à la balance et elle s'est fait jeter
c'est à dire que quand on vit dans un
pays où un mec dit vaccin c'est pas bon
il est jeté
c'est tout c'est à dire où nous sommes
en dictature qui profite le crime alors
qu'ils avaient su qu'il mène depuis jean
marais vous savez à quel point je vous
aime profondément
mais on est sûrement la meilleure maman
prouver
mais sur un autre débat j'ai
l'impression que je suis d'accord avec
benjamin qu'on fait le débat qui a été
tenu il ya un an
je pense profondément qu'on en est plus
là alors je suis contre le fait qu'on
vous censure parce que vous ne mettez
pas en plus leur aise quand je regarde
comment l'état mais en revanche celle là
vous partez tout à fait sûr une autre
sur un chemin de traverse qui n'est plus
d'actualité à l'heure actuelle je pense
sincèrement je me suis dit on peut tenir
et de détester hold-up ce qui est mon
cas
alors oui si je suis ici toi et ton
enfant si vos enfants un attrape le coc
vite vous jamais vous allez penser une
seconde je ferai peut-être pendant cinq
jours comme christian estrosi comme jean
luc mélenchon qui l'a déclaré sur son
blog
est ce que je ferais pas comme eux pour
tout simplement être guéri dans cinq
jours
mais moi non mais pas à ma question mais
il serait peut-être arrêter enfants brad
aussi jean-marie simon enfants demain
alalala qu'ovide je m'en remettrai au
personnel de santé
bah oui accès aux qui me diront ce que
je dois faire sur genêt seulement messin
traitant parce qu'on les a zappé mais
celui qui connaît le mieux que toi et
tes enfants et il leur a dit vous restez
chez vous nommé jim hughes et sur ce
qu'ils ont raté ray ya pas longtemps
pour toi dans mike à qui profite le
crime pourquoi est-ce que la guimauve
c'est la volonté
bah voilà de vacciner un maximum de gens
sur cette planète voilà le le thème les
spécialistes que moi j'ai vu que j'ai
entendu il te précise que cette
modification parce que jamais depuis les
hommes préhistoriques on a fabriqué un
vaccin en un an
ça n'existe pas il est ni vérifiée elle
n'est pas passée par toutes les normes
parent ou un vaccin devrait passer en un
an
attendez attendez c'est vrai tu as
raison jean marie sur le fait que
c'était très rapide il ya quand même des
flandres obligatoire qui sont les phase
iii d'un vaccin
ils détestent et tous les vaccins sont
passés par cette fable aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas mettre un vaccin sur le marché
sans qu'ils soient approuvés par les
différents donc c'est pas possible
et là ça a été le cas sur entre à la
chloroquine jean marc jean marie
aujourd'hui donc tu penses qu'on te
censure tu penses que ça vient de trains
jeu oui moi je suis un mec à qui est il
faut fermer sa gueule mais juste
jean-marie ce que tant qu'un
heureusement que tu me reçoivent alors
là je peut l'ouvrir mais jean marine
juste pour le shérif parce que tu te dis
quoi le président il t'a appelé il a
discuté avec toi il a essayé de voir un
peu ce que tu pensais pour essayer de
tact et un peu voilà ce que chaque
personne pense et je sais qu'il appelle
beaucoup de monde pour sa double et a
été très flatté et après tu poses qui
s'est retournée contre toi ben je pense
que ensuite la vague de 2 2 que j'ai
provoqué a fait que tout le monde a été
d'accord sur un truc mais tu pensais pas
que ça serait mieux que je ferme ma
gueule et jean marie s mais bon je te
poses des questions sache et je veux oui
j'aimerais que bernard montiel ou d'ici
là des impôts là tu es ce que tu penses
pas qu'il s'est senti trahi quand tu as
raconté à tout le monde quitte avait
appelé et que tu l'avais fait tu l'as tu
l'a rendue publique et que vous et a
donné un peu les continents et les
aboutissants des conversations je pense
pas que ces sacs à déchets aux poudres
je te demande est certainement que ces
indus le froisser je me suis excusé
d'ailleurs auprès de lui voilà j'ai cinq
autres français ont eu ces apu le
français oui mais moi il n'empêche que
coach je regarde moi les choses je suis
obligé par exemple si je dis un truc qui
va mettre tout le monde d'accord
1 là je vais vous dire pourquoi roselyne
bachelot je m'adresse à roselyne
bachelot roselyne pourquoi tu nous
interdit d'aller au théâtre
pourquoi tu interdit pas le métro ça
c'est une question alors ça alors quoi
on zappe et non mais même permet aux
gens d'être 5 par mètre carré
accroché à la même barre quand on sait
que c'est le toucher qui est le plus qui
transmet le plus le virus pourquoi
est-ce que tu interdit pas le métro
trinquons l'avion ça m'arrive c'est un
combat pas les médicaments baiia 1 aura
nommé par exemple je dis ça mène ce
combat je dis ça et là ça suffit à me
faire bouffer mon facebook je dire j'ai
même pas besoin de parler ni du
président ni du vaccin
on s'en fout de tout ça moi je dis que
c'est bien que le peuple
il est le droit de faire ce qu'il veut
si par exemple mon médecin mois de
famille mon médecin de ville comme les
appelle le médecin traitant
ils ont été retirés de la marmite moi si
mon médecin prend la responsabilité et
il dit oui je vais vous prescrire ne
serait-ce que le l'antibiotique titre
max qui lui n'a aucun effet secondaire
parce qu'elle lui tout seul déjà il a
des résultats
je veux qu'ils puissent le faire je veux
que mon pharmacien n'est pas lille roxy
chloroquine classé au tableau c'est de
sa pharmacie dans la catégorie des
médicaments vénéneux alors qu'on le
prend depuis 70 ans marie j'ai quand
même le droit de dire ça j'aimerais
revenir sur cette affaire avec le
président bernard est ce que vous pensez
que c'est ça qu'a mis le feu aux poudres
non mais pas du de moi je regrette
simplement s'ils adhèrent aux théories
aux théories complotistes de cet ovni
comme l'autisme
c'est à dire je trouve un autre nom ou
dans deux études j'avais vu tu fais à
régionales
j'ai tu me dis là c'est compliqué à une
puce pour contrôler et à la tête de ce
ce qu'ils sont pas des complotistes pour
moi sont des collabos marié en mai belle
gueule moi s'il avait accepté mais non
non non vous reprocher qu'il est unique
descendu au oui oui il est contre ça et
vous nous dites il faut avoir l'autre
test sinon complotistes qu'on va le haut
la main par vous passez à bas ces mots
là en plus vers le nom mais je voudrais
que vous préciser votre pensée vous le
dites il ya une entité supérieure qui
dit à toute la terre vaccinez vous
vacciner vous est-ce que clairement vous
reprochez vous accuser notre
gouvernement donc d'être à la solde des
labos pharmaceutiques
c'est ça c'est sûr et certain de 1,9
milliard par an pour nexar maé on écrit
veulent sur le trône
si vous ne tenez pas les poules et le
pouvoir de l'argent il faut bien que
tout le monde est à la solde de
l'industrie pharmaceutique tout le monde
y compris sans exception y compris la
première personne qu'il embrasse tous
les dix ans c'est le responsable de
laboratoire exactement dit lui dit tu
sais ça m'avait dit ça comme on l'avait
au téléphone tout bruit pardon il y
avait dit au président que vous l'avez
au téléphone non j'ai pas eu le temps
d'approfondir voit l'art et puis je ne
voulais pas lui l'attaqué de francs 10
ans donc alors est ce maquereau on obéit
aux puissances de l'argent
jean marie laure que sais tu te fais
quoi vous avez vu la nette entière quand
vous avez une présidente téléphone vous
étiez courtois avec le vous étiez
content et courtois vous avez passé un
bon moment
oui oui très bon moment alors si et mine
de rien vous pensez que voilà qu'il est
manipulé
est-ce que vous avez parlé de ça donne
c'est à dire que cc 4 temps que ne
comprendra pas que l'humanité va va
perdre son existence à cause de sa
cupidité
tant qu'on ne comprend pas que quand on
se met tant sur la table tu fini par
dire oui plutôt que non tant qu'on ne
comprendra pas que ces puissances de
l'argent sont filmés nal et que on
comprend tout à fait on peut tout à fait
comprendre sans être un spécialiste mais
on cède à la corruption s'est passé là
le monde qui est cupide comment il s'est
arrêté était cassé ils ont aussi on a
dépensé bien mais des centaines mais si
jean-marie messi mais ma mairie le plus
grand capitaliste du monde même le jeu
peut pas dire ça c'est pas connaissance
et arrêté qu'est-ce qui s'est arrêtée
tout s'est arrêté pour des rigolos maré
en fin d'année les compagnies et
m'assurer d'ailleurs ça va détruire sa
pensée c'est à dire qu'il se tire une
balle dans le pied c'est qu'ils pensent
diriger il serait plus intelligent que
non ça dépend avec mesa des pompes parce
que si tu vois par exemple si je regarde
un peu de plus haut tu regardes la
démographie du monde
on est sept milliards et demi c'est déjà
les propos parce que rien 3 milliards et
demi qui ne sont que des estomacs à
remplir
il est à dire écoute oui s'il te plaît
il ya trois milliards de personnes sur
terre qui sont on le on apprend ça dans
des facs aux états unis qui sont plutôt
des gens pas très utile
non je suis ne viendrait pas et ne
fabrique rien ils ne font rien marché et
sans eux les riches seront encore prise
et la question jean marie gleize ça veut
dire quoi qu'est-ce que tu es en train
de nous dire tu en train de nous dire
qu'on a créé de toutes pièces un virus
ce qu'elle dirait le virus parce que ça
alimenterait les labos lesquels labo
voudrait éliminer une partie de la
population passée les vieux ça ça leur
apporterait de l'art de l'argent etc
t'imagines ce que tu es en train de nous
dire que moi par un je reçois ça c'était
quelqu'un que j'aimais infiniment donc
je reçois ça je vais je vais te dire un
2 e s qui me raconte jean prat les rires
la vérité c'est einstein qui a dit ça la
vérité ne triomphe pas toujours mais
tous ses ennemis finissent par mourir un
jour ou l'autre et nous verrons ce que
l'avenir nous réserve
dans un avenir je pense à ses proches le
chaos qui nous attend jean marc
l'effondrement économique de la planète
jean marie jean marais les biens étaient
provoqués jean-marie ça va être terrible
jean marc ya plein de gens qui
réagissent à sur les réseaux sociaux qui
sont je te le dis et je te le dis parce
que tu étais mon pote qui sont affichées
par ce que tu dis sur les réseaux
sociaux qui disent ça n'engage que toi
et je te le dis je te dis moi comment
ils vont te dit tout alors on est on est
on est potes
c'est vrai qu'en plein de gens qui qui
qui se disent voilà qui peut pas dire ça
aujourd'hui parce que ça remet en cause
et est donc c'est des théories maquis
son ex a remis en cause beaucoup de
choses c'est sûr que ça retourne
beaucoup l'estomac
tiffany que vous les regards après jour
et nicolas oui oui non je trouve par
rapport au président est ce que vous
avez dit cyril la césure en fait elle a
été créée à partir du moment où il a
tenté de vous aider brigitte mal pourra
tenter de vous aider aussi et vous avez
déclaré ensuite sur vos réseaux sociaux
jean-marie que quand il s'était il avait
du mal à y avait demandé au peuple qu'il
avait du mal à s'adresser au peuple dont
qui s'adressait à vous c'est tout
simplement là où a été créée la césure
il n'y a pas quelque chose contre vous
il n'ya pas vous voyez ce que je veux
dire il est pas bon non non non il
essaye pas alors qu'il avait essayé il
vous a appelé justement parce que vous
vous sentiez brimés par rapport à la
liberté d'expression et là il va vers
vous il fait un pas vers bout il
s'appelle je pense qu'il vous a aidé
aussi à titre personnel quand il ya
quelqu'un dans votre famille aussi kaka
été contaminées par le virus il a aidé
brigitte macron vous a aidée aussi
quand il ya eu la fermeture de cette
fameuse clinique passé chaude un mélange
invoquera chien l'origine d'un conte qui
m'a appelé parce que je me suis adressé
son choeur de femmes et là tout le gotha
que ça sert à quelque chose parce que
tous les gens dans cette région de
bretagne voulait donc fermer cette
maternité et donc il pouvait le judas
non je ne veux moi j'ai pas fait j'ai
pas payer de ma poche une maternité au
burkina faso non mais je hais ce que
durant mille femmes à marcher sur la
terre battue
donc on enferme une chez nous ils sont
malades oui et pas cupides alors ils ont
raison et way touch et qui peuvent pas y
être qu'ils ont été embauchés par par
mois si si c'est facile de faire les
deux hommes ont alors tiré dans la jambe
et c'est vrai moi je t'adore mais c'est
ce que je voulais arrêter de dire je
t'adore il me les suis
non mais si ces jeux mari je t'adore
mais le plateau mais moi je sais moi
effectivement tu veux je te respecte
pour moi tu dis des grosses bêtises mais
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec toi
et là franchement tu peux pas reprocher
quand les gens font est pas près d'être
quand ils font c'est un complot ça n'a
pas de sens que tu dis ça n'avait pas de
sens dit que c'était un complot gambe et
les lots
déjà en 2001 avec la justice je suis un
peu plus tôt un chercheur un enquêteur
je demande pourquoi
et tu te poses la question dans ce pays
tu deviens un complotiste c'est tout
nicolas pernikoff mois jean marie je
suis désolé je vais te le dire là dehors
c'est vrai que tu vas te fous rires oui
on sait connaît déjà le cas du 11
septembre qui t'a coûté très cher et qui
a coûté une blinde pas écouté ta
carrière rires voiture revient tous les
deux trois mois sur deus de tous est de
3 ans sur les espèces de 8 à carrière
jean marie tu as un talent monstre ut1
les plus grands humoristes qu'on a en
france
la chauve souris le lâcher de salomé
toute saison qu'est ce que tu as dû
perdre dans ces combats qui sont en
train de ruiner ta carrière ternie sont
entièrement d'accord avec toi et avec ma
femme qui nous regardent chéri il a
raison qu'est-ce que je viens [ __ ] là
qu'est-ce que j'ai j'ai tout à perdre
c'est vrai rien à gagner mais bien de
mon point de vue je trouve ça assez
héroïque
jean-marie tout à l'heure tu disais moi
je suis je viens juste je pose des
questions moi je n'entends pas de
questions justement que tu viens de me
dire écoute moi va ériger m'interroge
sur les vaccins ça me pose question
parce que tout à l'heure on a eu ce
débat sur astrazeneca oui nombreux le
vario africains ou pas là je t'entends
mais quand tu me dis le veut le vaccin
c'est parce qu'on nous inoculent des
puces ou des machins ou le truc c'est
parce que ces jeunes gens mais tu veux
dire quand j'entends c'est parce que ça
va être
quelles sont mes frères par exemple sont
de l'adn et c'est là tu me perd là tu
m'a complètement perdue je n'entends
plus les questions j'entends jean marie
qui me dit à moi valérie je suis un
scientifique et j'ai les informations
que tu n'as mal mais donc quand tu
entends con tu vas tu peux plus
tapas c'est ce que je dis que tu jeudi
par exemple aussi puisque je suis plutôt
un enquêteur jeudi et quand on demande à
agnès buzyn gêné santé sait plus quoi
répondre
elle croise un des gros et j'en sais
plus quoi dire pascal y dans une merde
noire
pourquoi madame busin vous avez mis ce
médicament qu'on utilise depuis 70 ans
pourquoi vous l'avez mis au rang des
médicaments vénéneux elle vraie volonté
de nuire en sachant que son mari c'est
de lui que de l'obsession à autre chose
c'est de l'ordre de l'obsessionnel j'ai
vu ainsi peu importe où tu expliquer que
tu étais que tu avais pu beaucoup
d'argent tu t'en sors tu es pas très
bien en ce moment et c'est un peu
difficile
repas en tant qu'artiste remets toi sur
l'a16 fait jamais la lâcher at il suffi
je fais des choix du nom mais jean-marie
vous avez dit quelque chose d'essentiel
je suis héroïque
c'est une posture que vous avez rassuré
nous c'est une posture vous c'est vous
l'écorchée vive ou le rebelle vous
contre toutes les autorités vous contre
le monde entier met d'accord ça d'accord
et donc c'est votre posture qui vous
pousse à dire de telles extrémités
inaudible et délirante alors oui
peut-être mais elles sont inutiles pour
toi mais peut-être pas pour les gens qui
nous écoutent
guillaume moi j'en ai marre de cette
politique de censure qui consiste à
bâillonner toute personne qui dit
quelque chose qui va à l'encontre de la
pensée du gouvernement exact qu'il
reçoit quelqu'un que j'ai ainsi fait sur
le plateau oui mais pas lui qui m'aimait
bien
parce que je vous le dis sur les réseaux
sociaux s'est partagé mais aussi ya
plein de gens aussi qui pensent comme
jean-marie après ça n'engage que que lui
mais y'a plein de gens ici qui disent
voilà pour yann a pas un qui pense comme
si on m'avait dit qu'on reçoit quelqu'un
sur ce plateau qui pensent un peu en
dehors de ce qui est véhiculé par le
gouvernement ont le défoncer reliant
mallinder vous savez pas mais trop
mignon mais qui en fait un art oui c'est
reculer pas médecin mais nous est ce qu
on est médecin est ce qu'on en sait
quelque chose c'est un citoyen et la
droite donné son avis si les gens n'ont
pas envie dessus jean marie bigard il le
suit ça n'engage que lui regardez ils ne
regardent pas bon on va aller les effets
censuré par twitter censurer toute
pensée qui va à l'encontre de celles du
gouvernement ça s'appelle la pensée
unique et c'est très dangereux
ce qui remet à l'honneur jean marie
c'est de laisser entendre que le
président a été soigné à la chloroquine
alors que le canard je suis assise et
j'ai dit je ne savais pas s'il avait la
passion qui l'a pas fait non il l'a s'il
a laissé entendre
il a été le président qui s'est passé en
juillet on lui a posé la question lors
de l'entretien il n'a pas fait
traditionnel il a bien dit qu'il ne le
fera jamais de toute façon à ce que le
gouvernement a commandé 70 kg dj
chloroquine pour l'armée française
explique moi dans le contexte c'est un
moment c'était au tout début
non le virus arrive on le connaît pas du
tout on ne connaît pas très bien
aujourd'hui commencer à ce moment lors
didier la parole et tout le monde
l'entend gens mariés ils se disent
qu'est la wii est un des rares mais
comme étant un des rares mais la
conviction c'est bon c'est bon merci
jude jean marie bigard dont il est 21h15
je vous laisse là quoi tu m'appelles
jean marie bigard ça sent le référendum
d'habitude c'est mon jean marie bigard
cool
bonjour marie et moi je te laisse faire
la conclusion il est 21h15 qu'est ce que
tu as envie de dire aux gens et qu'est
ce que t'en veux dire à ceux qui te
sens-tu 1 je dis que nous sommes un
exemple la france est un exemple de
démocratie où j'aimerais que le peuple
est à la fois son libre arbitre et son
mot à dire comme vous l'avez très
gentiment signalé
si en ce moment on vit une période si tu
pas d'accord avec l'ensemble je deviens
un ennemi à abattre et je trouve ça
extrêmement dommage je préférerais que
tout le monde puisse parler librement
que tout le monde vis ce traité comme il
a envie j'aimerais que nos médecins de
ville et de campagne
nos médecins dread on puisse faire leur
travail qu'on ne les met pas en dehors
de la gamelle ils nous connaissent
depuis 10 20 30 ans et il savait
exactement ce qu'il faut faire
laissons les nous traiter les son nom
médecin traitant de nous traiter tout
simplement ça serait une très bonne idée
parce que ça pourrait être non ce risque
ça pourrait peut-être même
guérir l'ensemble des gens les éviter
d'aller en réanimation
pourquoi on ne met pas lorsque tous les
spécialistes scientifiques dirigent le
monde attend on ne meurt pas en fait
d'un manque d'oxygène
on meurt d'une thrombose c'est à dire
que les russes coffey des autopsies sur
les gens à mort du duc au vide ces
personnes qu'on a les caillots de sang
partout dans les veines c'est ce qui
provoque la mort dont marion wagon
ça n'est pas le cas vite sans pourrait
le dire par exemple on va voir oui à 33%
non à 67 % des gens comprennent pas qu
elles sont sûres et sur les réseaux
sociaux les gens à 67% ne comprennent
pas que tu sois et je sois censuré ben
merci les gens voilà les londons voilà
effet la compagnie qui mène un voile a
également son mari moi je t'adore
[Rires]